-♪ Guess who's back ♪
♪ Back again ♪
♪ Guess who's back ♪
♪ Tell a friend ♪
♪ Guess who's back,
guess who's back, ♪
♪ guess who's back,
♪ guess who's back --
Shoemaker ♪
Happy St. Patrick's Day.
You're maybe watching
this the day after,
but it's St Patrick's Day now.
I'm celebrating with
the most Irish of drinks --
the gin martini.
You've never had a gin martini
until you've had one
from O'Halleran's.
Very excited, we've talked
a lot about merch,
the need for Jackal merch.
Well, we timed it out.
We've had a lot of mugs
over the course of corrections.
It's time for Merch Madness.
We're going to go to
seacaptainpolls.com.
You're going to go there.
It's not actually
seacaptainpolls.com.
It's @seacaptainpolls
on Twitter.
It's a very popular handle,
I think, like 3,500 followers,
or something,
which is a big number.
But go there
and there will be brackets
where you can vote
on your favorite mug.
And over the course
of Merch Madness,
we're going to pick the mug
that we're going to insist
the NBC store carry.
I was pretty psyched,
you groaned.
I was pretty psyched when
I came up with Merch Madness.
So I told Chelsea, my assistant,
"Hey, before I drop this.
Pun of a lifetime.
Why don't you run over
to the old Internet
and by Merch Madness for us."
50K for Merch Madness.
But she told me --
because that was a hard no
from NBC.
50K for Merch Madness.
But they told me merch
with a U
$12 month.
So that's ours now.
That's ours.
Hey, last week we mentioned
the Jackal Briggs personality
test,
which is when a person says,
actually,
it's Frankenstein's monster,
that means they have
no personality.
And a bunch of you asked why,
when given a choice of making
a play on the Myers-Briggs
personality test,
why do you go with
Meyers-Jackal?
Little on the nose.
All right,
we've talked a lot about
why you're watching YouTube
if you don't like this.
Like why you're watching this
on YouTube,
if you don't like this with
so many options on YouTube
and this is a couple
of weeks ago now,
I said when you walk
into a grocery store,
do you just take the first thing
that you see?
And I'm like, "Oh, tuna fish."
And then you said, "You
obviously don't grocery shop
because tuna fish
is never the first thing
you see in the grocery store."
And then last week I said,
"Well, actually,
it's the first thing I see
because I use a VIP entrance
and it opens up into seafood."
And then a lot of you said,
"This also proves
you don't go to a grocery store
because tuna fish is not
in the seafood section,
it's in the canned
goods section."
And to that,
all I want to say is,
you got me.
I don't go to
the grocery store.
You know where I get my tuna?
The Omakase menu
at Takasawi's.
I said "IE" last week
and was told,
one does not say "IE" out loud.
You use IE in writing
and when speaking,
you say that is.
Which means the correct way
to sing "Old MacDonald" is
Old MacDonald
had a farm, E that is IO.
I had a little bit of fun
last week.
I had a bit of fun last week
obliquely referencing
the lyrics
to the Barenaked Ladies song
"If I Had $1,000,000"
and I reference
Barenaked Ladies lyrics
the reason anyone would --
click bait.
I referenced the line,
"I'd buy you
John Merrick's remains."
And it's been one week
since I did that,
and many of you
looked at me
cocked your head to the side
and said, I'm angry.
Is it because when you
were angry,
because while in the film,
The Elephant Man
is named John Merrick,
in real life,
his name was Joseph Merrick.
And -- but I was --
I was quoting the lyric,
it should be noted correctly.
But Joseph Merrick
was his real name.
And I guess France --
Frederick, excuse me,
Frederick Treves,
the surgeon who wrote the book,
is the one -- he actually --
he got it wrong.
I guess he got it wrong
maybe just by accident.
He maybe wasn't that good
on the details
when writing this story
about Joseph Merrick because
someone wrote -- someone said,
it's actually Joseph Merrick,
and he changed it to John
to protect his identity.
Feel like that's not enough
of a change.
It's like I'm writing a book
about you, but don't worry.
I'm changing your name to John.
So we're going to call
Frederick Treves,
Francis from now on.
Good back up.
I said sloths.
We've talked a lot about
sloths here.
It's the leitmotif.
I said "light" motif last week
and was told you
don't say the T.
Someone said,
I said a little sloth
was the last animal we're ever
going to have on the show.
And someone said,
"What about your dog Frisbee?
Do you consider Frisbee
an animal?"
One, I think Frisbee
was on before the sloth.
And two, I don't --
I...she's family.
I don't consider Frisbee
an animal.
I know it's irrational,
but I consider her a person,
the dumbest person I know.
We did a joke
about somebody was...
showed a Legoland ID after
getting arrested in England.
And then, the punch line
was they...
were charged
with resisting arrest
because they were snapped
into their car.
The details aren't important.
I was told there's no arrest --
no resisting arrest charge
in England.
I did not do
any follow up on that.
But I guess
you have the right to say
that any police officer
in England,
"Now is not a good time."
And then they just -- that's it.
They just go home.
That's why they never caught
Jack the Ripper.
They almost had him, and he was
like, "I got a thing."
I mentioned that I was
48 years old
on air this week.
I also implied I was 48
when I quoted
Barenaked Ladies lyrics.
I'm no spring Chinese chicken.
They get this in Canada, right?
YouTube?
It'll do so well.
Hey, someone reached
out and said,
"Hey, in the thumbnail that you
use in your YouTube photos,"
you know, the thumbnail photo
they use for the YouTube video,
"You don't look 48,
you look early 50s."
And so I went
and talked to Lloyd,
our Scottish photographer,
and said,
"Is there -- could we use like
a different lens or something?"
And he said,
the sweetest thing to me.
He said, "I don't think
you look 48.
I think you look a Scottish 30."
I always like to read
my favorite comment of the week.
This was, again,
a lot of people complain
that these are getting too long.
"If the correction segment,"
someone thought maybe I was
just throwing in things
that weren't actual mistakes
for the purposes
of the length of this segment.
"If the correction segment
only has enough genuine material
for three minutes,
then do three minutes.
Don't pad it out to 60 minutes
just so your hack writers have
something to do on Thursdays."
How dare you?
My writers don't
come in on Thursdays.
You're lucky if they're still
here at noon on a Wednesday.
Pad it out.
Someone thinks
we pad these out.
In what world?
Who would it benefit?
It's not like there's ads.
I mean, I'm --
I'm reading it right.
If the correction segment...
Two or three minutes.
Don't pad it out. Yeah.
The nerve.
Because this -- I mean, again,
it's not for the show, but...
There's an integrity to this.
Pad it out.
I mentioned my new book
"I'm Not Scared, YOU'RE scared!"
It's a very proud --
I'm very proud of it.
And one of the things
I'm proudest about,
and I've mentioned
this on the show
is the groundbreaking choice
I made.
It's the first children's book
to have both a rabbit
and a bear in it.
And a lot of you
have written me
that's not true.
And you wouldn't give me
examples of books that
have both a bear and a rabbit.
But here's something
that is true.
The time it took you to write
that you'll never get back.
Oh, this is great.
I mean, this is what --
this is my...
[ speaks indistinctly ]
I got a correction
from way back.
2021 corrections.
We talked about -- someone
clarified the difference
because we mixed up
Alice Cooper's chicken
and Ozzy Osbourne's bat,
and someone really put the time
into a long correction
about what we'd gotten wrong
about that.
And then I said,
the only thing I know to be true
about the person who wrote
that is that they are a stepdad.
And then that person, I guess,
just saw it,
you know, they're catching up
on their corrections.
And they said, "I am offended
that you would say that.
How dare you? I am a step mom."
Which is even cooler,
like a stepmom
who loves that brand of music.
Imagine getting that
in your life. What a dream.
What a dream.
"You kids listening to music?"
Oh.
Oh, hey, Debbie.
"Ah, Ed Sheeran, huh?
I'm pretty cool.
He ever eat an animal on stage?"
Debbie!
"All right. Rock and roll!"
In math --
I said in math,
we call that a given.
I was told in math,
we call that a constant.
A given is a no one cares.
Shoemaker is back.
I mentioned that up top.
If you're wondering why
there's sort of a buoyant
atmosphere to tonight
it's correct.
It is both the fact that
I've had one
half of one martini.
And that Shoemaker is back.
He's not that mobile right now.
Not that mobile.
A lot of sitting.
A lot of stretching out
on a couch.
He's definitely got a real
Wally in an H.R. meeting vibe.
His new catchphrase is,
"You're lucky
I'm stuck in this chair!"
I'm so happy to have him back.
I mean, have I --
have I called his doctor
and said,
"Are you sure he's ready
to do a full work week?" I have.
Only because he hit me across
the knuckles with his cane
and then blamed it
on his pain meds.
And then I said,
"What are your pain meds?"
And he said, "Advil."
I did say we were worried
because Shoemaker was zooming in
from what he said
was the hospital,
but looked like the Ritz-Carlton
in Puerto Rico.
I was told that's not possible
because the Ritz-Carlton
in Puerto Rico is under
renovation till later this year.
But I will say that Shoemaker
has often said
that one of his travel hacks
is to stay at places
with construction rates.
It did that a few weeks ago.
And then last week
I mentioned that people said
I looked like an old worn out
Ash Ketchum.
And then someone said,
"No, you don't look like
Ash Ketchum. You look
like the pizza guy
in a porn film
who just delivers the pizza
and leaves."
Eh, somebody order a pizza?
Oh, yeah.
I'll just take the pizza.
I said Peter's out.
No. Excuse me.
Yeah, I said, Peter's out.
No wait. What did I do?
I said Peter's off.
It's supposed to be
Peter's out.
And everybody's like,
"It's not Peter's off.
It's Peter's out."
But what I was
trying to say was "[Bleep] off."
So the Peter part
was the -- where my error.
I showed a really cool letter
last week from E.B. White,
a letter no one
had ever seen before.
And again, we've been
talking a fair amount
about E.B. White.
And boy, oh, boy,
did I hear it from you, jackals,
to the point that I'm not
even sure
it's worth sharing things
with you guys anymore.
So, you know,
it's this really cool letter
from 1953 and --
and a lot of you said
E.B. Write --
E.B. White, an accomplished
what writer like E.B. White
would never have
written the sentence,
"Is it [bleep] up that
two humans has a kid mouse?"
But they were like, obviously
the correct grammar is had.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe it had been a long time
since he used a typewriter.
And maybe this was
the eighth try
and this was the best one
by far.
And maybe whatever his
equivalent of a producer was,
was banging on his office door
saying,
"We got to go."
I don't know. I'm not him.
Maybe he had to be like,
this is, you know what,
this is good as
it's going to be today.
But let's let the man rest.
Why are you criticizing E.B.?
It's E.B. White.
Look at the date. We've talked
about that, right up there.
And then everybody was like,
oh, why did E.B. White
use a capital I for one
instead of a lowercase L?
I don't know.
Why doesn't
a typewriter have a one?
Why is it some weird riddle to
know where you're supposed to --
he's got all the other numbers.
I don't know.
Someone else said if you wanted
to make the letter look older,
you should have
dipped it in tea.
I -- Why are you telling me?
I didn't do this.
Look, it's signed by
E.B. White. Okay?
And I was so upset by this
that I reached out to
the Cornell University Library
which houses
the E.B. White Archive
it just so happens.
And, well, I unearthed
another letter.
And, you know, again,
very hesitant to share it
with you
after you guys were such jerks
about the last one.
But here we go.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
March 25th, so one day later,
and it looks like he did get it
right this time. Okay.
"Dear Kaye, wanted to circle
back regarding my last letter.
I'm realizing now there were
quite a few typos
and grammatical errors.
The fact is, I'm under
a lot of pressure lately.
My typewriter doesn't have a one
button, and it's driving --
It's driving me cuckoo.
Plus it's starting to dawn on me
that you're right.
And the ending
to 'Stuart Little' does suck."
Okay, pretty big deal.
"I called my publisher
and begged them
to let me add a proper ending,
but they're being
total dicks about it.
O.M.G. complain much, E.B.?
Thanks for letting me unload.
All the best
to your future endeavors.
Sincerely, E.B. White."
I mean, oh, and that's cool.
"P.S., if this letter
looks older than the last one,
it's because
I dipped it in tea."
All right. Well,
we're really happy to have
Shoemaker back.
Happy St. Patrick's Day.
Pad it out.
Because...
One more thing
I have to show you.
I actually don't think
there is.